oh hell yeah well I'm great I'm doing
okay I'm not so good because you were
weaving all over the road there well can
we get one thing straight
okay right hand with the left hand and
back out I need you to recite the
alphabet from Z to a backwards as fast
as you can Amy yeah sure z Y X WVU TS r
q p o NM l KJ IH g f e d c b a
[Music]
remarkable i've actually never seen
anybody do that
oh my blood oh I'm I'm not worried about
your bladder right now sure right
all right well you've got a pretty good
balance thank you I want you to step
bump step bump-bump step bump step
bump-bump five six seven eight step bump
step bump-bump step bump step bump-bump
potiphar ray kick ball change step clap
five six seven eight you know what would
be good is if you hitch kicked and then
you kind of did that and then a barrel
turn and in ha you know this girl would
weed that's really good you a dancer no
no no no not under drunk right now